a piece of British medical history for
Carley Barton and her consultant Carly's
thought to be the first person legally
prescribed cannabis based medicine in
the UK she's paid two and a half
thousand pounds of her own money for the
three-month prescription from a private
specialist to treat her chronic pain I'm
over the moon I'm overjoyed that this
that this has happened that this piece
of paper exists it will mean that I am
NOT concerned about having to take
consumed my medicine when I'm out the
house I don't I'm not going to have to
look over my shoulder to worry if
there's police there security there
anybody I might offend thanks to the
change in the law a month ago Carly can
have up to a gram a day of two different
kinds of cannabis flour taken with a
vaporizer a specialist says it reduces
her pain and spasms within 15 minutes as
a result of this he told Sky News she's
able to be no longer bed bound for days
on end and can resume daily activities
and is able to hold down a job as a
result of better control of her pain
there's a positive effect in her
well-being and quality of life but asked
about the efficacy of the system for
prescribing cannabis based medicine dr.
McDowell said it's drawn out at the
present time which is concerning
campaigners want GPS to prescribe the
drugs to make things simpler but not all
medics agree at the moment GPS don't
know enough about cannabis mate based
medication and I think it's going to
take some time for them to feel really
confident at the moment we're still
slightly feeling our way because we
don't have anything like the history of
prescribing medicinal cannabis products
that we do with opiates earlier this
year
Carly showed Sky News how she made her
own cannabis oil from illegal plants
though she's now thrilled to be on the
right side of the law she says the steep
price tag isn't right so when her three
months are up she's hoping to get the
same prescription but from an NHS
specialist paving the way for others to
follow suit
lorna Shattuck Sky News